well good evening I'm Trudy barage owner
of Canterbury booksellers a bit of
business before we begin as you can see
c-span is here and in the question and
answer period if you'll just project
your voice a boom like that we have here
will probably carry it Canterbury is
delighted to welcome James Weinstein
author of five books on American
politics founding editor and publisher
of in these times magazine founder of
the socialist review and founder of
modern times bookstore in San Francisco
many in this room this evening have
followed James Weinstein is writing over
the years some of you even call him
Jimmy and some of you have even played
softball with him
I personally not had the pleasure of
meeting him before this evening but when
I heard that she became politically
active at age 14 I immediately imagined
him as the young Nathan Zukerman
sympathetic protege of IRA Ringgold and
Philip Roth's wonderful novel I married
a communist this evening we've gathered
to celebrate the publication of Game two
Einsteins extraordinary new book the
long detour the history and future of
the American Left John Nichols associate
editor of the capital times and editor
as well for the nation has written in
the long detour james weinstein uses his
deep understanding of american history
his encyclopedic knowledge of the
successes and failures of the american
left and his own rich experience as a
journalist and activist to make the case
that this nation can still realize it's
radical promise james weinstein is the
rarest of all public intellectuals an
informed optimist this engaging in
trover view of the history of socialism
in the united states ends with a
question what is to be done
in these unraveling unsettling times
this is what we have come to hear kindly
help me welcome James Weinstein thank
you I see better without these actually
I've been called not an informed
optimist but a pathological optimist
this book is very hard to read excerpts
from to give you an idea of the entire
book because it covers so much ground it
starts in the early 19th century with
the communitarian colonies sometimes
called utopian and then it goes through
the beginning of the what we think of as
the modern socialist movement starting
after the Civil War which was
essentially a labor based movement and
it traces the the difficulties and
successes that it had and it makes
essentially the point that by the early
1900's the socialist movement in the
United States was an extremely important
influential movement that reached into
all aspects of American life and that
transformed capitalism from the
heartless ruthless competitive system
that it was in nineteenth century and
that it threatened to be with the
emergence of the giant corporations by
forcing the incorporation of most of its
demands into the mainstream of American
society and this was seen in the
Progressive Era and in and in the New
Deal and the interesting thing is that
much of what we now have as part of
American capitalism and that most people
think of as the nature of capital
war in the late 19th century and early
20th century far out ideas and programs
of the socialists things like
unemployment insurance Social Security
the eight-hour day the 40-hour week the
minimum wage workmen's compensation even
women's suffrage the Socialists were one
of the leading forces in that the first
advocates of birth control or socialist
women who went to jail for advocating
that in public of the dozen or so
founders of the n-double a-c-p
two-thirds were Socialist Party members
including WEP Dubois at that time so
these people were tremendously
influential and contributed to the
democratization and humanization of our
society well then I deal with the
Russian Revolution I have two chapters
on that and I show two things one is how
it threw back the whole meaning of the
Socialist Movement because it was
started it took place in a society that
had none of the developments that Marx
foresaw as necessary for a society that
could transform into something that he
thought of as socialism and instead it
made it through all the debates back
into arguments over the nature of that
society and the reason I call the book
the long detour is that this pretty much
paralyzed the American left and stopped
it from really thinking about how
American capitalism was developing until
after a fall of the Soviet Union so
there's a 70-year detour excuse me
then after the Soviet Union collapsed we
had a situation in which essentially
there was no meaningful left there were
efforts in the 60s to revive a left
along universal principles when that
collapsed instead of having a left that
stood for universal principles we ended
up with the remnants of the left each of
which went off in its own direction so
you and the women's movement the gay
movement the civil rights movement and
so on the environmental movement now I
wrote this this is an excerpt of
something that's in there as we've seen
this is from the 9th chapter of the book
as we've seen the disconnect between the
developmental needs of society had not
always characterized the left in the
first half of the 20th century socialist
ideas had served both the left and the
nation well when Milton Friedman the
prime Tribune of laissez-faire
complained that the United States was
more than half socialist he was
unwittingly paying tribute to the left's
role in those years that of course was
not as intent on the contrary like
Ronald Reagan he located the deep
insecurities generated by the new
consumer oriented economy at the left
doorstep today Friedman said we're much
less safe than we were when I graduated
high school we have much less feeling of
security
much less optimism about the future
about what the future is going to be
like and indeed the insecurities that
Friedman alludes to and many more are
real enough their underlying cause
however is not government a euphemism
for the left and what Friedman says it
is but the steady transition of the
economy from a focus on
industrialization to one on value free
consumerism military Keynesianism and
Empire the first part of this process
began decades ago in the 1920s but it
accelerated greatly during the Great
Leap Forward of industrial productivity
during and especially after World War
two as production increased steadily in
those years jobs and manufacturing did
not keep pace on the contrary they
relentlessly disappeared that presented
a dilemma to those in the upper reaches
of American society if a return to the
Great Depression was not to be avoided
and policymakers were seriously
concerned with this question after the
war jobs outside of civilian
manufacturing had to be found the deluge
of new consumer goods needed to be
absorbed this called for a new ethic of
popular concern
conspicuous consumption this was
fundamentally something new in
capitalism those of you who lived
through the depression know that only a
few short decades earlier scarcity
self-restraint and in the interest of
capital accumulation had dominated
social life now the ethic and the social
habits associated with it had to be that
ethic and the habits social habits
associated with it had to be retired and
a new social goal value free self
fulfillment through consumption had to
be promoted before the war before World
War two or at leat happiness or at least
satisfaction lay in having a steady job
but the hallmark of recent decades the
expansion and servicing of compulsive
consumption requires different habits
different family structures and
different attitudes towards work these
changes made many things possible many
of them very good one possibility was
articulated by Mario Savio and the Port
Huron Statement of the of SDS happiness
they said now required a self fulfilling
job or a meaningful career but the
expansion the vast expansion of
advertising
and consumer credit also promoted the
idea the happiness was having a new car
the latest shoes or the newest
electronic gadget and that is what
prevailed in most of society this
fundamental shift and the way people
measure their worth and in the nature of
the workforce opened up new living
choices that wreaked havoc on
traditional social relations this
includes the women's movement the gang
Liberty and lesbian movement this in
turn created fear and insecurity in
large sections of society
neoconservatives unable or unwilling to
locate the source of these changes place
the blame on the left a century and a
half ago Marx wrote that capitalists
quote fanatically bent on making value
expand itself were ruthlessly forcing
the human race to produce for production
sake he saw this quote blind process
driving the development of Industry to
create the material conditions that
alone can form the real basis of a
higher form of society one in which a
full and free development of every
individual would form the ruling
principle the good news is that thanks
to the genius of capitalist development
a society based on that principle is now
technically within our grasp the bad
news is that leftist continued to
operate within the parameters of the
trap set for them by the defenders of
contemporary corporate capitalism the
events of September 11th strongly
suggest that the time for the left to
examine the social possibilities
inherent in our material achievement has
arrived but they can do so only by
breaking out of the straitjacket imposed
upon them by those frozen in the habits
of thought and practices that dominate
thinking even to some extent on the left
in the world's last remaining Empire so
that gives you that's sort of the point
of the book but it covers so much ground
that I don't even know what other things
to read to you without staying up here
all night so instead of doing that I'll
open it up to questions and people can
ask me about any part of history from
the left since 1802 today well I may be
pathologically optimistic but I'm not
crazy I see it in the situation which I
the social situation which has been
steadily deteriorating in this country
and in the fact that now it's possible
for people on the left to really think
differently and to start looking at our
society and the potential that it has
and to start developing programs and I
have a chapter that suggests some of
them especially in the realm of
education and healthcare that will both
ameliorate that both of those problems
and at the same time create millions of
self fulfilling and creative jobs for
people in labor-intensive industries
because the solution to the problem of
our society today does not lie in
further investment and industry every
time we invest in industry we lose jobs
we don't gain jobs so we have to think
in terms in entirely different terms and
my optimism is that people will read
this book will have similar thoughts and
that when you think about it carefully
and you understand it at least the way I
do it seems such so obviously a better
solution to all the problems that we
have that I believe that people
be able to understand it if we can only
succeed in getting a significant group
of people together to start espousing
them these ideas supplies a great
transition for my question which is
about I was wondering how you view the
role of smoothly at the middle class or
professional middle class whatever you
want to call it and perhaps even more
particularly intellectuals such as
yourself in the development of socialism
or the left more generally both
historically and in the present
basically in other words how is the
class with the most direct access to the
press and the educational system and
things like that what is the influence
of them on sort of forms of socialist
activism well historically socialist
leaders the leaders of the socialist
movements the most productive ones have
all come from what has been
characterized as the middle class or the
intellectual class or what have you
the only real exception to that of
course was the Soviet experience and
that's one of the reasons it was so
backward and so horrible because Stalin
was a man of almost no education and his
paranoia was such that I'm just reading
a wonderful book some slight digression
a biography of Khrushchev by William
Talman and he shows how Khrushchev
succeeded in surviving and Stalin and
then winning the leadership by playing
the fool for Stalin because Stalin never
trusted any intellectuals or anybody who
was educated beyond himself and that
meant he didn't trust many people so and
if you read the chapters in the book on
the Soviet Union you'll see that the
level of intellectual and technical
development was extremely low and
extremely crude and was in large part
responsible for that country having a
political
philosophy that was really based on
Czarist principles and Soros precedence
but in the West almost every leader of
the socialist movement has been what in
Russia would have been called an
intellectual or a middle class person
and I think that's certainly true and in
the 60s it was the student movement
which indicates that also so I think you
need you need people who who know
history who know and who think about
these problems and who have the time to
think about them and to discuss them and
that these ideas then have to be brought
as they have always been to larger and
larger sections of the population and if
the ideas correspond to the realities of
the people you're bringing them to then
you have a chance of building a movement
does that answer your question
I'm just
I always interested just how do you see
those connections happening nobody knows
okay that's an easy
programs they were more or less an
attempt by the bosses really to
forestall the the ultimate demise with
the Apple ISM I don't necessarily
believe that they were what they were
progressive but I don't necessarily
believe that that was really an you know
pressure from below more than it was
that by the bosses to to head off any
really radical demands that is the
takeover of the factories and the means
of production by the working-class wait
a minute what are you saying are you
saying that the reforms made capitalism
to put a face on capitalism and it made
capitalism more palatable to the
majority of people yeah of course but in
order to do that they had to incorporate
the the programs of the left it's
interesting that the left's that existed
in the 30s I have a chapter on the Great
Depression also and what's what's really
interesting about that is that already
the organized socialist movement had
become marginalized in terms of ideas
but the ideas that they had put forward
in the first twenty years of the century
had been internalized by many people who
became the leaders of the various
radical movement so for example in
California in 1934 Upton Sinclair who
was a life time member of the Socialist
Party quit the Socialist Party and ran
in the Democratic Party on a program of
ending poverty in California well his
program was exactly the same as as it
had been when he was a socialist but he
won an overwhelming victory in the
Democratic primary he got more votes
than all the other candidates combined
and he came very close to winning the
governorship so that he created this
mass movement based on these radical
demands the same was true of Huey Long
in in Louisiana who grew up in
Wynn Parish and win Louisiana in a town
that had had was a populous stronghold
in the 1890s and in the early 1900's was
a socialist stronghold had a socialist
mayor and and he had been exposed to and
had debated socialist ideas all his life
and he advocated a very pro working
class to pro poor people's program and
he had a tremendous following and
Roosevelt particularly was terrified by
him thinking he was gonna run for
president and beat him in 1936 before he
was assassinated and the same was true
in Minnesota so yes these ideas did not
originate in the ruling class but the
interesting thing about them is that
even in these reform movements even Huey
Long and up in Sinclair and
what's-his-name in Minnesota anyway
doesn't matter now Olsen Olsen also was
a radical he belonged to the IWW for a
year when he was seventeen years old and
in Seattle
all of these people put their programs
forward publicly as programs designed to
save capitalism and that's what they did
morning on the radio it was very good
and you were dealing with some of the
problems that the left is facing is sort
of the broad spread of the left and how
we deal with the problem that we have
was a regime change in the white house
here and I wonder if you could expand on
that a little bit more be more specific
what do you want me to say well III just
I was thinking that you were talking
about that the the problems that third
parties have and the problems of of
dealing with the parties getting to be
different directions just more or less
about some more about what you were tell
I take I take my strategy my electoral
strategy pretty much from the experience
it's an extrapolation of that experience
but this is how I came to it of the
nonpartisan League in North Dakota in
1915 how many of you ever heard of the
nonpartisan League of a couple the
nonpartisan League the Socialist Party
in in North Dakota had existed for 15
years in 1915 they'd had some successes
they elected a few mayors and sheriffs
and coroner's and one state assemblyman
but they believed that their ideas were
much more popular than their party so
they started a group that was controlled
by the party but that required only that
farmers and workers sign a statement
saying I will only vote for a candidate
that espouses this program which is
their program and the the success of it
was overwhelming in fact it was so
overwhelming that the leadership of the
party got scared and and thought that
well the tail is going to start waving
wagging the dog and so they stopped the
program well the guy was running the
program with a party
Arthur Townley decided the hell with
them I'm gonna take this idea and
develop it on my own so he went around
and he organized farmers and workers
around the idea that they would in each
election district in each assembly
district if it was an assembly election
or any senatorial district or whatever
they would nominate their own candidates
because by now you had open primary laws
in North Dakota and anybody could enter
a primary all they had to do was sign up
and get enough names on a petition and
become a candidate well he said in
Republican districts will run in all the
Republican primaries and it was
essentially a Republican state in
democratic districts will run in all the
Democratic primaries within six years
they had total control of the
legislature they had elected both United
States senators and the governor and the
one United States congressman and they
maintained control of the state for
about twenty years and because the
movement didn't spread eventually it
dissolved but the point of that was that
they understood he understood that the
important thing was what are the ideas
and not having your own home and that
since the electoral system in this
country is legally wide open especially
on the level of legislative elections
that it is entirely possible for people
to do the same in any congressional
district and one of the great virtues of
that is and I talked about that in the
last chapter is that whereas you might
need a majority vote to get elected to
Congress to get the nomination you would
normally need only about ten or fifteen
percent of the vote because only about
thirty percent of the electorate votes
and primaries
and all you need to do is get half of
that so does that answer your question I
can't see so there's a lights good yep
what does it or something like you
suggest to have depends upon people
having information having control and I
simply don't see any possibilities in
the world right now where anything other
than the media conglomerates are
dispensing any information I only get my
isopropyl subscribe to a couple of
leaning left magazines and read books
such as yours
but I simply do not find any widespread
dissemination of anything even remotely
socialist in my day-to-day living
well you're not likely to I said no
you're not likely to but that's not
really the point the point is we don't
have any alternative but to attempt to
do something like this and you know I
don't know how many of you were around
in 1959 anybody who would have said in
that year well two years from now we're
gonna have a vital vibrant new left they
would said out of your mind
but we had it and there are many reasons
why it didn't succeed but the important
thing is actually you don't have to go
back that far every aspect of the
corporate and not so corporate media and
the political elite in this country
supported the war went right down the
line repeating all allies the Bush
administration told them and in City
after city around the country the
majority of people were against the war
now it's true in the country as a whole
that wasn't true but in Chicago I was
active in the anti-war movement there
when we started giving out leaflets at L
stops at five o'clock we we were a
little afraid to because when we had
done that in the early 60s when we
opposed the Vietnam War people would
spit on us tell us to go to hell
whatever the universal reaction was
where have you been where can I get some
of these leaflets and there was nothing
in the media that informed them of that
and in fact worldwide there were
millions and millions of people involved
in this mass movement so you can never
tell when something like that will spark
people to start thinking and that causes
them to develop their ideas further if
there is some group of people putting
forward ideas that make sense to them
and then in any case that's the only
that's the only alternative that we have
other than think a home and buy a new
car
gentleman's much like McCarthy took
socialism and made it into communism and
Reagan made communism what it is or what
it isn't today along with socialism by
Clinton moving to the middle I truly
believe that the next phase is as you
get there become more left you become a
terrorism or terrorist in this nation or
I are identified with a fringe element
and I think it's a very scary aspect and
I think that more and more of the left
hence Clinton has moved to the middle
and we don't have a left and I think
it's almost impossible to go outside of
the middle without being labeled
something that no one wants to be
labeled like you're coming well I don't
think that that's true but I do think
that there is a danger that people will
get so frustrated that they become
terrorists and I may think that this
recent war has in my opinion laid the
basis for a very great increase in
terrorism in the Middle East I don't
know about the rest of the world and
there are some people in this country
there always have been who resort I mean
the anarchist movement is pretty much
dead here but there's still a lot of
young anarchists who think in those
terms but that's not a left and they
don't represent Universal or democratic
principles anyway I also have a section
on that of course
you spoke about your role in the
anti-war movement so I was just
wondering what your response is to other
social democrats like Paul Berman insert
members of dissents editorial board who
did actually support regime change in
interact they've joined the imperialist
in a word you know I don't have much
regard from I know Paul Berman
personally and Todd Gitlin I've known
for 40 years you can't explain that I
mean there are always people who would
rather gain some form of prominence and
acceptability they go along with that I
think that their criticisms of some of
the things that the anti-woman or some
people did in the anti-war movement are
not wrong but they're irrelevant in the
larger scheme of things
yeah interested in your comments about
the work of a historian of socialism in
America specifically I read an earlier
book of yours about the rise and fall of
the Socialist Party of the USA decline
of socialism in America yes that was
thought it was very well written and so
now quite a few years later you've
written this book which is also about
two large degree of the history of this
idea within itself within its American
context do you care to say anything
about the change in your work as a as a
historian the change over that period of
years in the and the quality and the
coverage and the relevancy of sources
that is available to somebody who wants
to write about socialism in America
sources now than they were then when I
wrote my book there was very little
known about the old socialist movement
most of the historiography was dominated
either by the sort of liberal
conservative types or by communist
historians who always denigrated the old
socialist movement because it was so
much larger and more successful than
their own movement so that I hope this
is not a little boasting but that book
stimulated a lot of younger scholars to
write about different aspects of
socialist history in in the United
States and there's been a lot of
literature on it since then
and they've done a lot more research
than I did I didn't do any research for
this book in this book is stuff that
it's taken from my own experience my own
historical work and the work of dozens
and dozens of other historians whose
books I read and used it's a it's a
historical essay the other one was we're
supposed to be my dissertation so you
know it's a different kind of book but I
think anyone today has available an
awful lot of material if they're
interested in well it's you know I have
pages and pages of it it's nothing you
can do in a short answer the main thrust
of it is that education there two
aspects of it first of all making
education really equal for everybody and
that's a question largely of resources
and how you finance education public
education and extending it to preschool
education and extending it to university
education on a free or subsidized basis
so that's and I talked about that at
some length I have a section on the
debate between booker t washington and
WB Dubois about education the
washington's view was essentially the
same as ronald reagan's and george
bush's education was to teach people to
read and write so that they can become
good workers without thinking and the
voices view was that you have to educate
people to be citizens and John Dewey had
the same view about education so I
talked about that and the meaning of
education and then the nature of
schooling and how school should be a
unity not a place where you learn how to
discipline young children so I talked a
little bit about that
and there's something else just slipped
my mind but anyway that's essentially
how how I deal with the subject oh the
other thing is yes that that education
if it is seen that way that education
should also be something that goes on
throughout everybody's life so that all
people all workers should have the
opportunity to go back to school to
study things that they are interested in
that school should be open on weekends
and in evenings that they should be
community centers of activity that
parents should be involved in the whole
process etc and one of the purposes of
that is to make a socially constructive
way of employing the millions of people
who are being squeezed out of industry
yeah
it seems to me that the fundamental
problem is that we have a greedy bunch
of people who run the whole country and
they they have corporations that were
supposed to be controlled by the states
they're totally out of control
they own the media they buy it actually
run it but they also control it in other
ways that's the the it seems like the
essential problem but and we've got all
so many people like the democrats the
democrats are like really ten percent
better than the republicans i mean they
put off with lots of words that sound
good when you get a chance to do
something about some of these real
fundamental problems they don't do
anything and we and we have you touched
on this we have all these people with
their own individual saying its
environment it's the war it's anti-war
we see that real strongly here real
strong anti-war group peace group but
they're not really trying to go beyond
that it seems like they ought to be able
to see hey we got a drop the democrats
we gotta build another party either the
socialist part there are some other
[ __ ] oh why don't they see me well i
agree with everything you said except
for the last 20 sentences or so or ten
sentences first of all there is no
democratic party second of all there is
no left the problem is to create a left
and and the problem of the democratic
party is to understand that it is not a
political party it is a quasi state
institution it is legally open to
anybody i had this argument with I'm
nothing but Mendel his name is not
Mendel block but that's
Bernie Sanders when he ran for Congress
the first time as an independent
socialist and I said look why don't you
run in the Democratic primary and run as
a Democrat
oh I can't do that Democratic Party's
disgusting corporate control party it's
a-you know blah blah blah all the things
you said and a lot more okay so he runs
as an independent loses the first time
he runs again the wins which was
brilliant and wonderful thing but on the
other hand Vermont's a pretty unique
state and does not really reproducible
many places he goes to Congress what is
the first thing he does nobody knows he
goes to the Democratic caucus and he
says put me on some committees they look
at him didn't you say XY and Z well yeah
but blah blah so they strung him along
for a while and then they put him on
committees what is the next thing he
does he organizes a progressive caucus
who was in the progressive caucus 59
Democrats and Bernie Sanders and they
all agree with him on some things or
most things so the democratic party is a
coalition of parties and of interests
and the more people that get in there
whose views our left-wing or who share
these universal principles the stronger
that caucus becomes if if one of the
reasons it's so important to have a
Democratic House is that in a democratic
house many of the progressive caucus
people will be the chairman of many of
the committees and have been in the past
so to think of the Democratic Party the
way one of the problems is this people
on the Left tend to think of American
politics as if it were European politics
as if we had a parliamentary system
but we don't in a poem entry system a
party that gets 5% of the vote and 5% of
the members of parliament can become
part of the government the Green Party
in Germany the Communist Party in France
I mean time and time again you see that
because the government is part of the
legislature the majority of the
legislature creates the government that
doesn't happen here we have a
presidential system but we still do have
an open system especially for Congress
when you think about presidential vote
it's somewhat different although even
this year you have Kucinich Dean you
have Sharpton they're all putting
forward very different ideas I just
heard Ralph Nader today at 4 o'clock on
Wisconsin Public Radio and it was very
amusing because he's talking about how
if they don't allow Kucinich with whom
he agrees on everything apparently into
the presidential debates then he'll
think about running as a third party
candidate again well why didn't he run
as a Democrat in the Democratic
primaries in the year 2000 he would
certainly have been included in the
debates because he was the most he was
the most well known candidate in the
field and you know that's been my
argument with the Green Party but that's
a separate issue yeah
excuse me if you talk about this at all
what would you think that the idea of
joining
I wouldn't join any party it's not the
point isn't to join the party the point
is if I lived in a Republican district
that had a traditional Republican
majority and if there was a weak member
of Congress there and if I were 20 years
younger I would run for Congress in that
district as a Republican I don't care
what the label is doesn't make any
difference that's what the nonpartisan
League did they they elected more
Republicans than Democrats but they all
agreed on the program and they all and
they instituted the program but they had
a disciplined group of people they had
shared ideas they work together it's not
something you can do as an individual
that's the other thing that's so wrong
about American politics which television
terribly exacerbates that politics has
become a personal thing becomes a
attractive individual someone who can
either spend ten million dollars of
their own money or raise ten million
dollars to run for office the idea that
groups of people can organize and create
an electoral organization or machine as
they used to be called in the old days
has gone away but there are places where
that happens that's how Bernie Sanders
did it and there's no reason and many
others incidentally that's how how
Harold Washington did it to become mayor
of Chicago in 1984 three so it's not
that it can't be done it's that we don't
think in those terms anymore and that's
part of the point in my book too that
you have to you have to look at the
system as it is and find ways in which
you can intervene in the easiest manner
to get to your goal of actually getting
in a position where you can be heard and
have some
claud's
any of my hands I'm sorry I couldn't say
oh yeah save your idea is 100% right
that's good that's done exactly what's
your stuff yes I also make that point
the Religious Right beat me to this idea
is that America judges history by body
counts it also reacts to history by body
count
right now well our present warrior we
lose a hundred soldiers people's moral
compasses are not turned on us even
though there's 10,000 of the other
parties dead in these country we all
seem to realize what we're doing I mean
we've got depleted uranium people being
shot children being tortured UGA's iums
being knocked to the ground and that's
where resources are being destroyed we
don't seem to see this at all all we do
is caught the body come to get to big
history we seem to need a body cop but
you know which again I think and a lot
of these Arab countries are starting to
realize this is why you know every day
an American soldier is shot simply bring
that body cough up so the American
people can recognize what's going on
along I don't think that's why it's
happening but it is happen but that it
is having that effect if you if you look
at the polls the Gallup polls the
percentage of people in the United
States who still support the war it's
still a majority but it's gone from
something like 85% to 56% and it's gone
steadily down and the ones who oppose it
and say it was a mistake so the polls
graph sort of looks like this and it
could very easily cross over and when it
crosses over the Bush administration's
can be in a lot
trouble if it does cross over and what's
happening now just in the last month
they said 37 American soldiers who were
killed or wounded well the American
soldiers over there - are getting very
very nervous and you know they're going
to have to do something about that and
it may be too late to do what they need
to do I understand that but that's not
my point for me and loosing arms and
legs is considered collateral damage or
a casualty it's not a statistic in our
warriors so I again we're being
manipulated on though of course we're
being manipulated but the point is that
manipulation is having less and less
success and that may or may not be a
cause for optimism yeah
would you care to reflect on what you
think it's key achievements and your
cheap regrets about it are its key
achievement is survival my regrets I
think is that maybe I stayed there to
home because it really wasn't reaching
out beyond its existing circle of
readers and influence but was a learning
experience I was there a mere 23 years
you know it was a great experience in
many ways and it was a horrifying
experience and many
I used to wake up in the middle of the
night in cold sweat thinking how the
hell are we gonna make the payroll this
week so I used to tell people that I
started this newspaper to be an editor
and I ended up being a beggar and that
was pretty much the case yeah
there's two practical points your basic
philosophy on education if you just
publish that as part of in these times
or something else it's absolutely
perfect I would say okay well yet get
the idea across it's in chapter 8
chapter 9 and chapter 9 and we'll talk
and all people will read it in the book
then would read it and in these times we
will talk about and one other point I
hear a plea here we're looking for
leaders to have good leaders you must
have good workers with good minds and if
people will get out there and help the
leaders will show up otherwise they'll
never show up well you know who is that
somebody I had this discussion with
somebody about what we need is an
individual leader to come forward and
you're absolutely right movements create
leaders leaders do not create movements
and that's been historically true people
who get engaged in a real social or
political movement in that process
leaders emerge so the important thing is
to start the process not to wait for the
leader haven't see me after you give
them the opportunity yeah yeah you you
know along those lines actually I was
wondering what you thought about the
labor labor movement and its prospects
that's current moment well the labor
movement is essentially an industrial
labor movement and industry is
disappearing I mean the end of
industrial workforce is disappearing so
the long-term prospects aren't very good
until unless they are Seguin to do which
they are doing by the way organizing the
workers who are the lower paid mostly
immigrant minimum wage workers and
especially the SEIU and if I'm one or
two other unions are doing this on a
fairly large scale and are having some
success but that's where the organizing
has a chance to make some real
difference and I think the unions are
doing about as well as they can in this
situation but they're in a very very
very difficult situation you don't have
much cloud if if you're in an auto plant
where every time they get some new
investment they have to layoff 5 or 10%
of the workforce and no matter how much
you fight against that eventually that
that's gonna happen because that's the
way capitalism works
okay oh sorry I don't know steps me that
there's some sign that the establishment
and the media are beginning to be a bit
harder on bush than they were for a
while I think they're getting scared
that he's he's going off in all
directions in the he's they're scared
about the economy is there any way we
can find to make use of that to
strengthen the opposition I have no idea
but I think you're right I think there
are elements in the pardon the use of
this word the ruling class who are
nervous about bush because he's not the
most responsible person in the world
and if he goes down they go down I mean
they don't go all the way down but
they're affected direction to do tell
different balance in the next election
you know as well as I or I should say I
know as well as little as you before you
nobody knows I mean you know you have to
think about it and there may be some
ways I don't know
I know he would be very happy to
inscribe books for you and thank you so
very much for coming like pretty much
polished off this glass anything you
want me to say or you just want me to
sign it subscribe where's k1 since they
anus to speak with citizen Abraham
Lincoln